-My first guest is
a Golden Globe-nominated actor
who's been getting great reviews
for her performance
in the movie "Mank,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Here is Amanda Seyfried.
Ah! Look at -- yeah.
Thank you so much
for being here.
[ Scat sings ]
I'm so happy you're here.
Love your background,
by the way, too.
[ Knocking ]
It better be someone I --
-That was an intense knock.
Yeah, go on in and you're
stuck for a minute.
You can go up.
Yeah, no, no, you can go
up here, this way.
-I'm getting nervous.
-Come on in.
Sorry.
-[ Laughing ]
I'm in a temporary home.
Our dryer is broken.
[ Laughter ]
And there's a chair in front
of the gate [indistinct]
and my husband and daughter --
-I just got so scared.
Oh, my gosh.
This is the funniest thing.
Are you kidding me?
Good.
You have to get that.
No, you have things to do.
You have things to take care of.
-But also,
did you hear that knock?
-Frightening.
-It was so aggressive.
-I felt like I was going
to be interviewed,
like in
-It was going to be
-"Dateline."
-a [bleep] SWAT team.
Yes.
-I thought something
was going down. I go --
I want to talk about "Mank."
Obviously, I have
a thousand questions,
but I want to get
into this interview
because you posted something
on Instagram recently --
and that's how I get my news --
-Same.
-and it is your first
magazine cover.
Can we see this photo?
Now, at first I go,
I kind of --
I didn't understand
what was going on
because it's Clay Aiken.
-Sure. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-He's on the cover as well.
-[ Laughing ]
-But right there,
front and center...
-Can we zoom in?
-...whose face do you see?
Mine.
-Yeah!
[ Clapping ] Aw, come on.
-Look at that cutie.
-How exciting is that, though?
You're on the cover
of "Entertainment Weekly."
-It was so exciting.
A big deal in our family
and I've never been on it again.
-[ Laughs ]
-Not that I'm sad about it.
It's just -- Yeah.
-Wait for Clay to have
another album
and then we'll start talking.
-Yeah, okay.
Yeah, no, I didn't think
about that, but that's true.
-You've been on many, many
awesome magazine covers since.
You've had a great career.
You've been getting rave reviews
for your latest movie, "Mank."
You got your first
Golden Globe nomination,
so congrats on that one, buddy.
-Yeah. Thanks.
Thanks. [ Laughs ]
-How was how was the virtual
Golden Globe experience?
What was that like?
-Preferable, because I --
-Really?
I could do without the
red carpet hoopla
because it ends up being
like a cluster eff
and, as fun as it seems
and as glamorous as it seemed,
it was really awkward.
You know, it's a pretty
awkward place
and you're being like thrown
and forced everywhere.
I have my kids on the floor
in front of me --
comfortably --
while I was sitting there
watching the Globes.
And I could do things between,
like at commercial breaks.
It was great.
-Did you get to talk to anyone,
besides your kids?
-The DP from "Mank" is
in town where we are
and he's shooting
my husband's movie, actually,
and he came and took pictures
with his wife.
They're wonderful.
And I talked to Glenn
and all first-name basis,
now, I guess.
Glenn, Olivia...
-Wow! Oh, so you got to talk
-...Helena
-to the nominees.
-Jo-- Yeah. Yeah.
And I kept seeing Olivia
going like this
and then I realized
she was asking for the baby.
[ Laughs ]
-Aw!
-And so I held the baby
up like --
Like, you know, in "Lion King."
-[ Laughing ]
-and then I felt like I was
taking too much time away
from everybody else.
Yeah.
-You crushed it, though,
You play this Hollywood
actress, Marion Davies,
and, man, are you stunning
in this movie
and just, you can't take
your eyes off you.
It was fantastic.
Did he film that
on regular cameras?
How did you pull that off?
-It's called David Fincher
and his brain.
He collects the best
of everybody.
The best production designer,
the best costume designers,
hair and makeup -- everything.
Everybody is the best
at what they do.
He made an authentic world.
He recreated the San Simeon.
and I mean, I don't know.
I was just -- I was very --
I was cast in October
and we started shooting
in November.
I just had to quickly keep up
with, you know,
study her and research her
and do as much as I could.
I mean, the script was perfect.
But it was incredible.
It was so fun to feel
transported every day.
-Yeah.
-And then walk past the monitor
and see it's all
black and white.
What?!
-For people who have not
seen "Mank," yet,
can you tell everyone
what it's about?
-"Mank" is
about Herman J. Mankiewicz,
who wrote the first draft
of "Citizen Kane," which is
-[ Clapping ]
-the greatest movie
ever made, right?
For a lot of people.
-Yeah.
-And it's about how he wrote it
and why he wrote it
and where he was.
And the backstory
behind "Citizen Kane,"
which is this
big newspaper magnate,
based
on William Randolph Hearst;
and his wife,
based on Marion Davies,
inspired by Marion Davies.
They're not the same person.
-Of course.
Like it's really great to me
to be able to clarify,
you know, the difference.
-It was so fun to watch
and so it didn't --
You know, I know you've been
on the show so many times.
It was just great acting.
It was like I was just in --
-Thanks.
I was like watching
a different person.
It was amazing.
But it was just beautiful.
Fun to watch.
Congrats on all the nominations
and the awards buzz
you're getting for this.
I want to show everyone
a clip from the movie.
Here's Amanda Seyfried
in "Mank."
Take a look at this.
-I need a favor, but you're
going to have to promise
you won't laugh.
-Given the state of the world,
a tall order.
-You're gonna.
I just know you are.
-I have got such
a hangover right now,
there's just a fighting
chance I won't.
-I'm being burned at the stake
and I am dying for a ciggy-boo.
[ Laughter ]
There!
God's punishing you.
Watch those stairs.
They're treacherous.
-Every moment of my life
is treacherous.
Any last words?
-Welcome to San Simeon.
-I've written worse.
-You've never seen it?
-No, but George Bernard Shaw
was right.
-How's that?
-It's what God might have built,
had he had the money.
-Well, as they say in the Bronx,
"Make yourself to home,"
Mr. Mankiewicz.
Or shall I call you Herman?
-No, please call me "Mank."
-Amanda Seyfried, everyone.
When we come back,
Amanda and I are putting
our singing skills to the test.
Stick around.